Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And
Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
Do Da, do the, how's your
fucking Cuba call old ado.
Dot Day. Um, what's going on? Happy
Thursday, everybody. You're almost there.
I'll tell you this weekend. Just
cannot come soon enough. Oh,
fucking suck it up,
Mary.
They're paying you to do you do a
fucking job. Go ahead and do it.
What are you gonna do this weekend?
It's gonna make you less of a fucking
God damn wet diaper to be around next
week. This weekend can't
come soon enough. Oh yeah.
Who you're hanging out with that you're
going to dump all your fucking problems
on. Sorry, you wouldn't know
it, but I'm in a great mood.
I'm in a fucking great mood.
Um,
tomorrow morning I'm
taking an early flight.
I'm flying out to a casino
in Maryland doing, uh, uh,
one or two shows out there. I'm
not sure. I don't know what,
just point me at this stage and I will
go out there and do my little fucking
dance, but a red sox finally won last
night. What did I do? Did I call it
or did I not call it?
All of these guys?
I don't know why you guys continue
to watch ESPN when the Monday morning
podcasts in the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast exists.
Okay.
Why do you put on that? Okay, Joe.
Okay. They're professionals. Okay.
They went to broadcasting school.
Okay.
They pay attention to sports way
more than I do. Having said that,
according to my ego,
nobody reads the sports
tea leaves better than me.
Yeah,
of course it isn't true,
but the one thing I am right about
is all these people that flip out
during the regular season about Gotti
records and all that shit and all the
fucking wins. The Red Sox
half, we've seen this before.
We saw the Seattle Mariners Stewart,
they want 120 something games
came home with no fucking,
they came home with their
pockets turned inside out.
And I'll tell you right now,
there was a,
there were a lot of lumberjacks in
Seattle crying on Monday. All right.
No, I know. Then I have a well earned
reputation as being a bit of a combustion,
a bit of a fucking wet blanket,
a bit of a fresh cut,
alright, guilty on all counts.
But I'll tell you one thing,
I'm right above other than my
misogynistic opinions about women,
I,
I am right about the regular season,
okay? And I'm here to tell all
of you to fucking stand down
with this screaming and
yelling on every fucking sport.
Kate,
fucking relax.
What you want to do is you take all
the stats of all the fucking 90% of the
teams or whatever sport you're watching,
sometimes only 40% if for watching hockey,
the amount of fucking teams that
are not going to win the playoffs,
you take all of those fucking stats,
all right?
As the rock used to say,
you turn him up sideways,
seven straight up the candy because cause
they don't mean shit cause you're not
gonna see those people
come fucking October.
So what did I sing when I jumped on
the Red Sox bandwagon six hours ago?
I said we got the Indians twice.
We got the Houston Astros and we got
the Yankees to more fucking times. Okay.
Now if we lay waste to those teams, I can
get excited. But even then the playoffs,
a diff Joe Bucks there,
there's more cameras.
Everybody's watched. All right?
People get a little tight.
You never know what the fucking happen.
So anyways,
I've been telling you guys and
yes I am pat myself on the back.
I told you everybody's sleeping on the
Indians and Terry Francona and what
happens? What does Terry do? He comes
right out in the first two fucking games.
He makes us look like a 500 ball club.
Handled us with ease.
That's two wins. Two more. And
you just took a series. All right.
I know we got Chris sale and
I know we got price. Okay.
But that's only going to get us to there.
All right.
And I think Terry Frank Code is the
best manager in Phuket baseball.
And then never, evidently they got
this Guy Brad hand or some shit closer.
I don't ones, no phone. I know his
last name. His hand. All right.
Very impressive. Lights out. I know
we won last night and everything,
but I'm just saying, you know, but that's
what they do over there. The ESPNs,
the Fox sports,
they are in the business of saying the
sky is falling or sending something to
the fucking moon. They send it to
the bone and when the sky falls,
they have the balls to say, what happens?
What happened? Rather than being like,
wow, we will, we will fucking wrong again.
All they do is hype shit up
over there. They did. I mean,
how many fucking times have they s how
do you compare the DD dd 2018 red sox to
the 96 bowls?
MMM.
And it's always the 96 polls.
By the way,
everybody ignores the 1983 Philadelphia,
70 sixers.
Okay. One of the most underrated
teams of all fucking time. Um,
anyways, I was very relieved
that we got a win last night. Uh,
I'm going to try to
watch the game tonight.
MMM.
And he'll be split with
them, but, uh, I, I,
I mean I love our manager and all
our players and all that shit, but I,
every time I see Terry Francona,
basically she's the best. You know?
I don't know what happens.
You just have just like,
familiarity breeds contempt. Is that
what is, how do you say that word?
Familiarity. Familiar. Familiarity.
Hang on a second.
That's one of those ones.
You start the word and then
you get halfway through
and you're like, oh my God,
I'm not going to make it.
And do you have like,
you're talking to three people
at the same time, the party,
you just see all of them ever so slightly.
You see their faces drop and they
realize how dumb the person they are that
they're talking to her.
Sorry for mill year air t
didn't even spell it right.
All right. How do you say this? Okay,
everybody, here we go. You Ready? Whoops.
Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Familiarity,
familiarity, rarity. Nope. Familiarity.
Familiarity, Yardi. Familiarity.
Dude. You know what it is? It's his
field. Familiarity of the ballpark.
He ain't fucking scared
when he gets sick on a cat.
He knows all the nooks and crannies.
I said it right.
Yeah. Already. Yeah. Familiarity.
You don't look, you don't believe me.
Listen to the fucking robot.
White Guy in my computer.
Familiarity C, go fuck yourself.
Give me a bud light kit. I'm
watching my waistline for the end of
the summer. Speaking of which, oh,
and then the Red Sox, uh,
they had some fucking little
a, as the English would say,
a little cheeky fucking tweet
there. I didn't like it. You know,
we apologize to our,
our fans for, uh, our,
our lengthy losing streak.
Why would you do that?
You know,
this is what you got to ask yourself.
What would bill Belicheck do? All right,
I just loved that over the
net. Hey, fucking cheat.
I know you guys would say that I cut
the sleeves off his sweater and fucking
blind a child to get an ice cream
cone quicker year. All Jealous. Um,
but funny anyways. Uh, yeah.
Why would you give Bolton board material?
Why would you motivate any other
fucking team? You know, that's just,
I think that's a stupid move.
Um,
and that's what happens when you go on
Twitter and they probably read all these
red sox fans. Freaking
the fuck out. You know,
if they got 50,000 tweets,
I bet 30,000 was sent by Dan Shaughnessy.
Oh, I always get to make fun of him. Um,
is this the 1978 season all over here?
Are they going to chant 2013 at us?
Um,
anyways, tonight, tonight. Big, big,
big fucking match of who's on the for
the Indians? I have no idea. But uh,
the Indians, oh, my team. If the
red sox don't make it this year,
I'd like to see them get one,
even though I'm going to have
to watch people in the stands,
have those stupid Cleveland shirts
that say defend the land. Uh,
I just kidding.
I think that might be the worst one.
Okay. Yankees sing. Why MCA or the seventh
inning stretch? You think that's bad,
right?
That, eh, go, yeah,
here's all these fucking fat hair.
He fucking Brooklyn cuts. Right.
You think that's bad. And then you go up
to Boston and this what is, what is it,
sue eight?
Uh Huh.
The thing is is you got to have
like a song for dumb people.
You know, like if you just
hum the melody of why MCA,
it's a Buddhist monk would probably tell
you that some sort of zen thing where
you just have a complete inability to
have any sort of thought in your head.
You know,
like think about your
future, why you go. Yeah.
[inaudible]
no, that's it. It's over. Um,
and then the temple of it,
young man walking down the fucking street,
cause you can't dance, right. Just
white guys walking around in a square,
you know,
is your girlfriend looks
over their shoulder at the
black guy in the background.
MMM.
Anyways. And you just think it can't get
any bad worse than that. You know? I mean,
that's pretty bad because
it's, it's Douche behavior
combined with music. I mean,
that's usually takes the cake,
but defend the land,
the land,
what land? Cleveland. He'd be the
one you guys all fucking abandoned.
It's a fucking ghost town.
Drive in from your fucking
plush neighborhood.
All those fucking rich cuts out
there in greater Cleveland. You know,
when their gated communities sitting
out there reading their broths in their
fucking 14 carat big green eggs,
you know,
then they come downtown like
the fucking Paul Revere.
I'm going to defend the land and go to
a game for three hours and then quickly
retreat back to my Culdesac,
the Lexus fucking riding mower.
The amount of money in greater
Cleveland is just insane, by the way.
I have no idea what greater
Cleveland is like. Um,
but anyway, is it, is it
that much difficult to be
greater than Cleveland? Oh,
see what I did there. Sorry.
Anyways, having said that,
uh, I love the idiots. My Dad
was a big Indians fan growing up.
MMM.
Indians at tigers where there's two
teams as he moved around a lot there. Uh,
so anyways,
I'll speak to that late last night.
MMM.
I somehow, you know, went down this, this
fucking, you know, what do you call it?
The rabbit hole on Youtube.
And I ended up watching this youtube
video about every quarterback,
the Detroit lions I've ever had,
you know,
and uh,
they met a lot of fucking quarterbacks.
Not a lot of offensive lineman, but they
have had a lot of fucking quarterbacks.
MMM.
Fascinating. Fascinating franchise.
Allegedly it's the curse of Bobby Lane.
It isn't, it isn't. It's not. Okay.
You know that to say that you're cursed
is just you just passing the buck.
It's like, no, we don't know what the
fuck we're doing and we need help.
It's not the curse of Bobby Lane.
What?
Cause he left a little disgruntled.
Yeah, you get rid of me.
You're never going to win again.
And then some old lady I heard he shed
for 15 years and that's how it starts
that Dan Shaughnessy
writes a book about it.
It makes a bunch of money off the misery.
That's what it should be. His next book,
the curse of Bombay.
Okay.
Bobby Lane would come into the
game fucking half in the bag.
He need hair of the dog after fucking
the second quarter going and halftime not
listen to coach,
slap his fucking wife around.
And then he'd go out and he'd have
a fourth quarter comeback, you know?
Um, and anyways, that's the way they told
the story. But I remember Greg Landry,
Eric Hippel,
I remember Joey Harrington his whole
fucking career just running for his life.
You know, that's what's amazing. You know,
when you see like some of these
people that are called bus like the,
this ship, this should be
like a consideration for the
fucking team you went to.
You know what I mean? Like
if Jim had, Johnson did not
come into the fucking Dallas cowboys
organization and make that Herschel Walker
trade, how long would have Troy
Aikman lasted in the league?
The amount of hits that that guy
took me the first couple of seasons,
he guy was on his back. You can only
take those hits for so long. Now.
I'm not saying Joey. Eric did his
fucking Troy Aikman I'm just saying,
remember way back in
the day when John Elway,
the Baltimore Colts drafted him and
he was, you know, and he was like,
I'm not going to that fucking franchise.
And they go, what are you talking about?
He got run the play baseball. I'll go
fucking play baseball for the Yankees,
you know,
because you guys don't know
what the fuck you doing.
And I have one shot at this and
then they traded him to the Broncos.
Koby Bryant did the same thing drafted
by the Charlotte Hornets. Zach,
I'm not fucking playing out there.
I actually think it is
like an for basketball.
It's bullshit for baseball
would be bullshit.
Those are like non contact sports
for the most part compared to like,
you know football, football.
I get, it's like dude,
I'm literally going to be drinking out
of fucking Straw by the time I'm 30 if I
play for you guys. Alright, you
don't have an offensive coordinator,
you have no offensive line. And I'm just
gonna get like, I'm going to be like,
you know the guy, he waves his hand
for a fair catch and just get stuck.
Now you know,
something with the new rules of tackling.
Now maybe I think that you
can go to these franchises.
You don't have to pull an airway.
Um,
yeah cause I guess that you
can't lead when you fucking,
you can't leave with your
head where you go to tackle.
I'm trying to picture halla how
do you do that? That can, can you,
you can hit with your shoulder though,
right?
But there's no way to hit with your
shoulder without leading with your head
unless you just sort of like a,
you just come jumping by like a
pogo stick and just sorta like,
it's like slam dancing.
Maybe they should do that.
I think what they should do is they
should have a giant velcro belt around.
All of them right in the ball becomes
velcro and you just stick it on the person
and the person can't run that.
You bounce down the fucking field like a
pogo stick and then everybody else hops
after you and tries to bump into you,
but you're not allowed to slap the ball
away the way a rod did when he ran down
to first base. I don't know.
I'm just trying to fix the game.
You know,
who the fuck does,
I know it's all about concussion
protocol and all that.
I think they should just have NFL players
just sign a release being like, yeah,
basically. Um, you got to take
about 30 years off your life.
Okay. But in the three and a half
years you play in this league, okay,
you're going to have a,
you're going to get more pussy.
You're going to drive more goddamn cars
in a more fucking blinged than you could
ever dream of. All right? So
joy, joy, well, less. Okay,
just sign here and you
can lead with your head.
Maybe that's what they have to do.
I Dunno.
Maybe the NFL implodes and then the
WNB takes over. I mean, who knows?
There's a good story for ESPN. Is
that what's going to happen? Um,
anyways, let me read a little
bit of advertising here. Um,
then I'm gonna talk
about, uh, my dog, Cleo.
Cleo is back in town.
I'm gonna go take her for a walk after
I upload this Fucker, a butcher box.
Everybody. Oh my goodness. Oh my
goodness. Are you a kind of war?
The love,
impeccable cuts of fucking
butchered meat the way I do.
I literally read this.
This is disgusting.
I literally read this in my mouth waters.
That's how much I enjoyed it. Plus also,
I'm on this fucking, this diet, you know,
and this week is like the
vegetarian diet. You know, I,
I had like a quarter of a chicken breast
at some point, you know what I mean?
An animal has to die so I
can live. I mean, it's just,
it's just how I am, you know?
Um, anyways, I just wish they
didn't treat the animals like shit,
which is why I like this one. You know,
these guys, they, they treat them night.
They pet them, they rub their
bellies before they kill
them. You know what I mean?
I mean, if you were going, if you were
on death row, wouldn't you want that?
You know, Nice head
rub, foot rub, you know,
work out the kinks in your back for
they flip the switch. All right.
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass
fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chickens and
the greatest thing ever.
Heritage bread,
pork,
the Cuban cigar of pork.
Okay.
Uh,
the incredible quality of butcher box
meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of
antibiotics and hormones before we kill
them. Each box comes with at
least nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24
individual sized meals.
You can choose from five different
box types. I disliked it.
You can order a couple of boxes of those
and you're ready for the apocalypse.
Just phrase those bad boys and everybody
else is going to be all starving out
there eating dandelions
in fucking flossing their
teeth with the flag in their
mailbox.
And you're going to be coming out
there with just full of fucking protein
throwing elbows and knees, Huh? Um,
you can choose from five different
box types. All beef, beef and chicken,
beef and pork, and a mixed box
for are you progressive people?
Custom box lets you choose
your own cuts. Oh, this is for,
this is for the fucking chef right here.
Antibiotic and hormone free.
We already said this.
Butcher box believes in a healthier
food system where everyone has access to
meets the way nature intended.
Free of antibiotics and hormones humanely
raised on an open pasture before we
kill them.
Shots fired at the company,
the artist formerly known as Monsanto,
Monsanto,
Monsanto.
Um,
put your box carefully curated
the final selection and cuts.
It makes it a breeze to
customize your own delivery,
build your own box to get exactly
what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequency
with customizable subscriptions.
Receipts Are Available on recipes,
receipts,
recipes are available on the butcher box,
websites and videos.
I literally thought like,
is this meat like tax deductible and
videos are available to follow along on
butcher box, Youtube Channel? Uh, I, yeah,
they wanted me to say my personal
experience. I told you I had the,
the heritage bread pork was the best
pork chop I've ever one of the top three
I've ever had and I've had five
unbelievable ones made by five star chefs.
It was just an entirely different level.
It's like, did you ever just like,
you have to have a tomato at a grocery
store and then someone has a garden and
they bring that over and you're like,
this is what the fuck it's supposed
to taste like. It's unreal.
It's like our food has a mute
button that's been pushed,
so every once in awhile when
you get the the real shit,
you know,
she's just so fucking weird that,
if you went back to the 18 hundreds
how much better food would have tasted,
but then all the other shit
you could have died of,
you know?
Then you fast forward all that shit they
died of and now our food's all fucked
up, which is causing more shit that
you'd die from. I'll tell you people,
it's a quagmire. All
right. Legal Zoom fact.
Most Americans don't have a,
well not this guy all set.
My affairs are in order.
20 years ago,
that wasn't a shocking statement.
You had to find a trustworthy attorney
and pay them by the hour to draft your
will,
but these days there's no excuse.
Legal Zoom has made it
easy to create your own.
That's why more than a million people
have used legal zoom for their estate
planning needs. It's an, it's national.
Make a will month@legalzoom.com so now
it's your turn to take control of your
family and assets within a state plan.
It starts with the will or living trust.
I can tell you this,
a lot of guys don't do it because you
don't want to contemplate your own
mortality. I gotta tell you, I was
one of those guys. I got to will.
I got everything all done and uh,
it was like a load off of my fucking
chest. You feel great afterwards,
you know,
unless you're married the wrong person.
And then they immediately start
to poison your food. I mean,
there's always something. There's
always a fly in the ointment anyways.
Don't know which one's right for you.
No problem.
Legalzoom's network of
independent attorneys will
advise you on what's best for
you and your family. Plus
legal zooms, not a law firms,
so you don't have to pay hourly rates.
Make things a lot easier on
your family when you're gone.
Checkout legal zooms last will and
living trust to state plans now during
national.
Make a will month@legalzoom.com yeah,
you don't want to fucking die and then
have your loved one's worrying about how
they're going to pay for their fucking
fruit loops or corn flakes or maybe
you're a fan of the Czech family.
Rice checks, corn checks, we checks.
Right?
And for special savings,
be sure to enter code burr in
the referral box at checkout.
That's code word for special savings
only@legalzoom.com where life meets legal.
Then you have to hunt your
own funeral because you sell.
You're an unsettled spirit.
Okay.
And then you're just going
to be screaming. I'm sorry,
like you're in ghost but,
but you know what? He's not there, so
no one's going to be able to see you.
All right.
Get a fucking wheel. Okay. Oh
[inaudible] Biondi she died with Datto.
Well they do dude.
[inaudible] that nobody can fucking jail.
They got no money now this suck your
dick out on the street doing it quick.
They do what they do because
they need to eat some checks.
Thanks for fucking us over, dad. You
really screwed us. All right me undies.
You've heard me obsess over my me undies.
You've heard me talk about how they are
three times softer than cotton. Well,
you've heard me read about it and
come with fun new prints each month,
but I got evidently I got a big scoop
that evidently I'm so excited to share
with y'all.
Me undies just gave their
membership a massive upgrade.
I just pictured them like there's some
sort of shelf they have in the front of
the underwear now that just lifts your
junk. There's your massive upgrade,
Huh?
Of foot rest for your balls.
All those dirty old, whole written
disgusting underwear you've hung onto.
It's time to throw all that out and
give your top drawer the refresher it
deserves.
Each month be undies.
We'll release a new exclusive
print that only members can get.
These could be collaboration's with Adis
brands or other unique designs you are
going to definitely want to have.
Members were also pay
less for everything on me.
Andy's website with
special member pricing.
That means if you want
a second pair of undies,
a Bralette or lounge pants,
you'll pay less than anyone else.
The membership comes with no strings
attached. You can switch styles,
skip the month or canceling any time.
Uh, you're going to love these Sundays.
They're the softest underwear you'll
ever put on and they come with fun prints
that can match with socks or a bralette.
Uh,
they come with 100% satisfaction
guarantee. If you don't love him,
just send him back grouse,
uh,
for a full refund beyond these has
a great offer for my listeners.
For any first time purchases,
when you purchase any Mandy's,
you get 15% off and free shipping.
That's a no brainer.
Get 50% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on.
Lastly, but not leastly.
He looks everybody. Alex,
there's nobody on the planet like you.
You're so unique.
The sound you make when you sleep,
the high pitched way that you fart.
So why would you buy a generic
mattress built for everyone else?
Yeah. Next, please mention all
the talking points below. Okay.
Helux Helix sleep matches your body to
the perfect mattress so you get the best
sleep of your life.
They developed,
they've developed nine
different mattresses tailored
to specific body types and
sleep preferences. That's amazing.
There's nobody on the planet like you,
the seven and a half billion people and
they've made nine different mattress
types and they think they
covered all the basis. Well,
I would say that Helux Helix
is talking a lot of shit here.
I think they're pretty confident that
God damn product just go to helix.
That what's sleep.com/per take,
their two minutes sleep quiz.
You sleep in the nude and they'll match
you to, to a mattress that perfect.
That's perfect for you.
Contouring to your body to provide
unprecedented comfort and better sleep.
36% of Helix Alex sleep customers report
better sleep after switching to their
customized mattress from helic
sleep helix right now helix.
Right now they're offering up
to $125 off all mattress orders,
whether you're a side sleeper,
hot sleeper,
like a plush or a firm bed,
they've got the mattress
that will fit just right. Uh,
anybody likes a fucking plush mattress?
Is it just they're not motivated?
You know? Whoa. I like a plush mattress.
Get up to $125 off. He looks like
helic. sleep.com/bar. That's helix,
sleep.com/pro for $125 off your mattress.
Order heavily asleep.com/berm.
All right,
let's wrap it up. Boop,
boop. Wrap it up. All right,
Billy botox is getting in shape.
That's right.
I'm going to get some injections in my
face. I'm going to have my teeth bleached,
my tongue scraped, and uh, you know,
the wind have that candle stuck in my ear.
He fucking melt out all the wax or some
shit. No, I'm not doing any of that.
I'm just trying to get, I'm trying to
get my abs. I got a four pack right now.
My stomach reminds me of
the old fucking wine cooler.
I mean that Oh bottle and
James belly right here. Um,
it's abs sick. It's Ab five and six.
Those are the tough ones. You know,
even seven and eight aren't that bad.
Like the fat just goes right to five
and six. It just fucking sits there.
You know what I mean? Like,
you know, whenever you, you,
you pour some liquid into a measuring cup,
no matter how much you
try and dump it out,
there's always that little bit
that fucking gathers in the bottom.
And then you try fucking snapping it down.
He gets kids always going
to be a little bit left.
And that's what ab five and six
are like in my fucking world. Um,
I'm doing all right though. I look
really good with the shirt on right now,
you know, but if I take my shirt
off it's still put it back on. Um,
so I think I need to do a little more
cardio or something like that. Uh,
you know what I want to buy,
I don't Rogan is,
has been talking up this fucking
cardio machine. I got to check it out.
I've got to go next time I do his
podcast, her right am in the area.
I ran into him the other night and I was,
I was,
he was going on and on about how fucking
unbelievable this thing and how it was
tiring him out.
So I figured if it tires Joe out,
it's borderline going to kill me.
Um,
but I remember way back in the day,
um,
there was gym and they had this
thing called Jacob's ladder,
which was just picture you were a fireman
and there was a ladder that reached up
to the top of the fucking skyscraper.
Right. And that's what it was like.
It was like you're on all fours and a
like a 45 degree angle and just climbing
this fucking never ending.
It just keeps going and going and going.
You know, it's like a treadmill on a 45
degree angle. They, they didn't, they did,
it's like you fucking crawl 10 miles
away from the gym and then you're like,
fuck, now how do I get back to my
car? You know, it just, you know,
goes in a circle using your own
weight or some shit like that.
And I remember I got on that fucking
thing and with it within three minutes,
it felt like my heart was in my
throat and I had done an eight ball.
MMM.
So I'm considering getting one of those.
I might buy one of those or a,
I'm going to check out the Joe Rogan was,
could chose how he chose always.
Like he's always sees one of those guys.
He's always looking around the corner.
So he's always,
he knows what the next shit is.
And I feel like he's had that thing long
enough that if that he's already past
the, Oh wait a minute, this thing
sucks. He was still raving about it.
So whatever the fuck he got, I'm going
to, I'm going to try to get, you know,
and then maybe I'll have a spinning heel
kick at the death level that he does.
Um, anyways, my dogs back in town.
MMM.
I'm gonna go take her for a walk. I
fucking miss that dog so much, man.
I'm having a lot of here.
Uh,
it's just the best,
but I still get to see her like once
every six weeks and she's out here for six
days. So every day I've been
taking her on like a fucking hike.
She goes nuts when she sees me.
I go crazy when I see her.
It's always a little sad when
I give it back, you know?
But uh,
yeah, I think she's kind of used
to it at this point. You know,
I think human beings take
it harder than, than, uh,
the fucking dogs do. But
anyways. Um, okay. Let's,
let's look a little bit of world news.
Let's see what's going,
let's check in on the
world. Everybody, uh,
Trump under fire for claim of large
scale killing of white farmers in South
Africa.
Um,
is there any doubt that this guy is just
a straight up fucking racist at this
point?
It's amazing how long he kind of hid that.
Like he had no idea when he
was just sort of this funny,
famous for being famous guy.
Um,
but the things that he chooses to focus
on, not saying that this isn't happening,
white farmers getting killed
in South Africa, but you know,
white people are killing a lot of other
people from different races for quite
awhile. A actually right now, I mean,
oh, I'm sorry. We thought
you were terrorists.
Will you just a family go into the market.
Sorry about that.
We've been doing that for 15 fucking
years. I mean, just, you know,
I'm not saying what's going on in
after I've read about it is right.
But it's just like that. Like, I
dunno when you can see like, you know,
when there's like neo Nazis and you
can kind of see their argument to,
well, you know, it's kind of six
of one half dozen of the other
and the fact that fucking politicians
on both sides are such pieces of fucking
shit that they will,
they will sit there and they will just,
they will tow the fucking company line
because they're grossly under fucking
paid and it's all about getting reelected.
So someday you can write three books while
you're still in office and then buy a
$10 million house.
That's basically what it is.
A UK outlines plan to
avert chaos of a no deal.
Brexit. When the fuck is this thing going
to go down? I thought they were leaving.
This is like the longest break up ever.
What is a no deal? Brexit. So they,
they leave the European Union and then
they don't know what the fuck they going
to do. All right, so they're showing a
picture of a bunch of tractor trailers.
All right. Make a difference in today's
world. Support independent journalism.
Subscribe for a dollar a week. Oh,
can I read what you wrote first?
How do I know you're independent?
This is New York times.com.
You're not fucking independent.
If mainstream, uh, London,
the British government issued its
first contingency plans on Thursday for
leaving the European Union without an
agreement seeking to prepare the public
for possible disruption without spreading
alarm that could undermine support for
the entire undertaking.
The government on agreement for what?
Citizens of other countries that are
living in London with some sort of work
visa. How are you going to
trade with the rest of it? Oh,
this is looking like a shit show.
The government emphasized that it hoped
and expected to hammer out a deal with
the European Union,
but in a series of technical documents,
it warned that without an agreement,
importers and exporters could face
significant new bureaucratic hurdles that
credit or debit card payments in
continental Europe could cost more.
And that British citizens living in the
block could lose access to banking and
pension service. I'm going to
call this right now. He, uh,
England or Great Britain leaving,
uh,
the European Union is either going to be
the greatest or the worst fucking move
ever. I mean, it's a great
move on some level, I guess.
Do you get out of the world banks
and you get to go back? They wait,
are they on the,
I can't remember if they were on the euro.
Are they still on the pound?
Where are they on the euro?
Did they go back to the pond?
I can't fucking remember,
but that's going to be that this is
either gonna fucking make other countries
want to do it or they're going to be like,
thank God I didn't do that.
There's not going to be, well,
you know what I mean? You know,
there's pros and cons. It's going to
be great or a show, one or the other.
I just want ESPN on that. Uh, US,
China imposed fresh round of tariffs as
escalating trade wars shows no sign of
ending. Why can't wait?
What are we doing? Well,
why can't we just fucking get along
with people, you know? Hello China.
How are you? Is this how you want to
run your country? Well, God bless you.
This is how we run our country. You
know, you want some apples? I mean,
how fucking hard is that?
I know,
I just oversimplified it
anyways. Um, oh, lastly,
but not leastly. Uh, I did, uh,
an episode of Conan O'brien last night
to hype my show at Madison Square Garden
November 7th.
I'll be there with Joe Barton,
nick and the pride of Trenton,
New Jersey,
Paul Versey on November 7th.
I'm very excited about
that. And a, as always,
I had the best time on, uh, on Conan ease,
him and Andy,
they're the best.
Colin's sets you up and
then if you get in trouble,
Andy saves you actually joked with
Andy when I left. I said, you know,
I think you only end to save me one time,
maybe twice.
I think he jumped in twice.
So my idea of a perfect game on
Conan is Andy never has to save me.
He's always two to five
times every segment. But um,
I had a great time. I actually got
there a little bit early. Um, and um,
I got to go check out the drum kit,
which was,
was fucking bad SSD W kit.
So I sat down and actually played
them for a couple of minutes and uh,
I don't know what that is.
That always like makes me more
relaxed before I go out and uh,
yeah.
Then do a show. I don't know why.
Maybe because I'm a fucking lunatic.
I have no idea. So I actually got to
sit down at James Woolworths kit. Um,
sounded amazing.
I was like,
you sure he's not going to get pissed if
I sit days egg. That's fine. Good. Um,
but, uh, anyways, I had a great time on
it. If you'd like to see some clips, uh,
maybe we'll, I'll post some links
or something like that to it.
I had a great time as always.
I'm so thank you to everybody
over at Kona for helped me, uh,
promote Madison Square
Garden November 7th. Uh,
please get your tickets so I'm not
standing there in a big empty arena.
All right. That's the podcast here
for a Thursday. Have a great weekend.
You conch. Enjoy this.
Um, music interlude here.
Musical interlude before we,
uh,
play some classic hits from a Thursday
podcasts from earlier in the year of
fucking 10 years ago. I have no idea
how it works. All right, I'll see you.
[inaudible]
let's get back to this out
here. I, uh, had a great time
last night. Um, I did, uh,
surprised, not so surprised.
Um, guest spot at, uh,
on the fucking, what the fuck?
The, uh, the, all the all in tour.
Sorry guys. I've you, can you tell him
and drinking again? Drinking again.
Oh baby. I'm Drake. And again, I went 73
fucking days with that, without the booze.
And uh,
Versie Bart,
nick in law had all came in
Saturday night after, um,
my second show over here at the Mirage.
And,
uh, I came back to my room
and I was waiting for them.
They were on their way up.
Kevin Shay opened for
me. All right, so all,
all the fucking maniacs.
We're out here and I'm sitting there
with the lovely Nia and she's going,
I'm tired. I'm like, I'm
tired too. I swear to God, if
these guys weren't in town,
I would just go to bed.
And they showed up.
We had a couple of drinks,
made some cigars sitting on a table, and
I go to my wife, hey, you know, like,
let's just, we're just going
to go outside, smoked a cigar.
I'll be back in a couple of hours
or whatever. And that was like it.
I don't know what that was. That was
probably just a little bit after midnight.
And I don't, you know, I started
drinking and I just became that guy,
that guy who just wants to keep
going and does not want to go home.
And a Bart,
nick was joking,
said what we did was basically they could
have shot a commercial for Las Vegas
is what we did. Um, I hate to say it.
We did and we just did old school Vegas
shit that was not old school when I
first started coming to Vegas,
but I've been out here for 15 years in
like the new schools go into the Dj Shit,
so I know what the fuck
we did. We signed that.
I think we ended up over the Venetian
and uh,
we were already smoking cigars. I don't
really even remember. I was just pounding.
Well,
where are we?
I played roulette somewhere and
I made money and I cashed out.
Then we went over to the v Venetian.
I remember playing craps,
throwing the dice, and
it just kept going. Hey,
I started yelling and everybody's saying,
I'm throwing numbers over here. Right.
I just started throwing.
I did what I always did.
I bet to six of the
eight and the past bar.
I should have bet the point
I hit the point twice. I
threw like fucking, I dunno,
1215 numbers in a row,
you know I was bullshit
man. I had like five bucks on each fucking
thing or whatever I made and I made a
couple hundred bucks cause I
was too drunk to realize like,
you know what you feel in it?
Why not throw down a little
bit more, but I didn't.
And it's people on the other end
of the table. Well going, hey,
you're built bar, you're throwing day. I
go, that's right. They're buttoned down.
I'd throw a numbers.
I was talking shit.
Oh it was Elvin elevator type tip and
people doing what you're supposed to do.
Laughing my ass off. I made
money. I went back over,
cashed out.
I had like fucking three $100 bills in
my pocket after starting off with my own
hundreds. So I guess I
was up 200 bucks. Now,
all of a sudden this shady dude comes up
to us who had this weird little sodas,
zipper scar on his nose and
he's had us a fucking flyer.
Oh wait,
somewhere in there I met these two
Asian chicks and I talked them back into
their dreams.
I can't answer that.
I'm just one girl.
She was an accountant.
She wanted to be in fashion and I
was like, so go do that. She's like,
do you really think I care Mike?
Yeah,
you totally can just keep your day job
and just start working on the fashion
thing and then eventually fashion
thing will surpass your other thing.
She was like, you're so awesome.
And all I'm thinking in my head is,
this is why that fucking guy was able
to buy where the Houston Rockets used to
play and go in there and talk about Jesus.
What the fuck is that guy's name?
You know that guy, you know?
Oh, what is his fucking name?
He's got the squinty eyes. He closes
his eyes and he sits there. You know,
Jesus wants you to have a popsicle.
He wants you.
All you gotta do is just tell people
what they, what they want to hear.
And I was totally sincere
when I told this woman
to go follow her dreams,
but I didn't really give her
any sort of concrete plan.
All I did was just tell her that she
could do it and it made it feel good.
So I did do a good thing,
but you know something, I,
if the bottom falls out of standup comedy,
that's what I'm going to,
I'm going to turn into a
motivational speaker. I,
I would absolutely crush it because I
already know how to make people laugh.
And then, uh, rather than be in a
negative comment, I would totally turn it.
I would finally take off like,
yeah,
you know, you don't want Spiderman wears
that black suit and he can't control it.
And he starts acting like a cunt,
you know,
start to talking shit to women and
spraying web web juice in their face.
Then he goes back to the, the classic
red and blue, and then he's like, oh,
I'm sorry about that, sweetie.
Let me get that. Um, oh shit,
I didn't finish that fucking story.
So this guy with a Goddamn Zipper,
stark scar on his fucking nose,
he convinces us to go to a titty bar,
which really wasn't difficult.
And next thing you,
we're in this fucking
titty bar and on, these women
were really goddamn aggressive.
Like the second you sat down, one of
them sat in your lap and I was like,
it was really, that'd be honest
with you. It's fucking suffocating.
I actually just kind of like,
Hey,
can you fucking let me
just get my bearings here
before you put quit trying to shake your
tits. They're fake. They're not moving.
All right. What do you do
next? Shake your elbow.
MMM.
So anyways,
we're in this fucking place
and uh,
I dunno.
I mean we're old guys. We don't
give a fuck. Next thing you know,
it's like six o'clock in the
goddamn morning. Six something.
We came walking out,
it was broad daylight and
I'm sitting there like,
the only thing I can relate it to
was when I was playing up in Alaska,
when,
uh,
when it was that one of those times a
year where I had like 22 hours of sunlight
and you were inside the club and you're
drinking and it's about two in the
morning. Like, all right guys,
I'm tired. I'm going to bed.
And then you would walk outside,
you'd open the door into broad daylight
and immediately your body's clock,
you would wake up set at two in
the afternoon, two, two at night.
It seemed like two in the afternoon
is the only way I could describe it.
And I walked out and uh,
all I heard was Kevin Chaise.
Maniacal fucking laugh at
like how light it was out. Um,
so that was my,
basically,
that was my first night out here
and I gotta be honest with you,
I'm still recovering from it.
And that was two goddamn days ago.
Last night after our show.
I was just like, I sat down
and I got something to eat.
I had one Budweiser and then I went to
bed and I was fucking psyched to come
back and go to bed. So that goes
back to what I was talking about.
So I have to dress maturely and right now,
like I was ever a guy walking
around a tank top. I didn't,
I didn't have any fucking a pigment,
you know, but I gotta tell you,
you got out on the pool. Some people, I
don't know if they just have, they just,
they can't see it or if they just don't
give a fuck some of this shit that
people wear it down by a Goddamn pool.
I mean,
it's just like, can you put that all
of that shit away? Can you put it away?
Half the people at the pool should be
wearing like one of those bathing suits
from the roaring twenties you know,
where it was basically it was
kind of a mechanic suit like that.
Phones are used to wear that one z zip up,
except you would cut the sleeves
off and you would cut the legs off
as what guys would wear.
And women wear the same thing and they'd
have a little frilly thing going around
the outside. Now it's unreal, man.
Oh Jesus. And my generation,
Woo. It's, it's ugly.
The tramp stamps the barbed
wire tattoo around your arm.
It's just a,
it's not a good fucking [inaudible].
It's just not a good one.
[inaudible] Hey,
what's
going on? It's Belper and it is the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
August 23rd, 2010. How the hell are you?
What's going on? I uh, just
got back from Portland,
Oregon actually taping this a Sunday
night cause I got a bunch of bullshit I
have to do tomorrow.
Um,
I dunno what the fuck I just got back
from Portland and I hate doing these
things Sunday night because I'm
still like jet lagged. I'm out of it.
So, uh, this is gonna be a rough
one and I'm plowing through this.
Even if it fucking sucks,
I'm not stopping it and rerecording it
like I did last week because that ended
up getting me in trouble.
That's how I started talking about that.
Dr Laura Shit last week.
And I got to say for the first time,
maybe the second time ever,
I'm nominating myself as Douche bag of
the week because last week I actually
supported Dr Laura Cause I had no
fucking idea who she was. And uh,
you know, I was having a rough time
doing the podcast. I needed some fodder.
Somebody send me an email,
what do you think about this?
And I watched like a ten second clip of
evidently a five minute clip and I just
thought she was imitating
something, something she saw
on def jam. So I was like,
well she's quoting it, she's not
calling anybody that word, but the, the,
the bed and all that bullshit.
And then Jay's, oh Jesus.
The fucking emails came in
from a I ever deadly. Uh,
for my 14 podcast listeners.
Evidently like six of them
are African American. Um,
and uh,
yeah,
they read me the riot act in different
stages and I've got to admit they will
fucking write cause I didn't,
I didn't, you know, something.
My uninformed logic is usually funny that
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about and I go off on shit and I realized
that our race probably isn't one that
you should probably do that on. I
didn't know that. She was like, uh,
like rush Limbaugh with the comment.
I had no idea. I just, you know,
I don't know the fuck she was that she
was some soccer mom with a podcast,
you know, at, she was like all the crazy
kids out there, fucking blah blah blah.
I had no idea. Sorry.
Fucking eggs on my face. Um,
but you know, it's funny, one guy got
so into fucking trashing me, wait,
before I close this email,
here's something I got from uh,
a former marine talking
about that clapping for, uh,
the troops going through the
airport. He goes, as a former marine,
nothing was a bigger joke than seeing
those support, the support, the troops,
stickers talk about an empty
gesture and is even lamer.
I've always fucking thought those bumper
stickers with stupid support the troops
.
She does Sligo by that for a buck slapping
on the back of your truck or car and
then he just drive away. Well, I did
my part. Do you support the troops?
Have you looked at my bumper
sticker will. All right then. Um,
yeah, that's fucking lame. Um,
he said clapping is even lamer.
He said you're on the right track. Sending
over drinks to veterans who got back,
but think bigger. How about a
program called head for heroes?
That's right.
Every,
every service member of returning from
whatever fucked up Third World Shit hole
we're engaged in at the time gets met at
the airport by some gorgeous whore and
blown in a specially designated area.
That would be a great way of
showing the country's gratitude.
You know what? I think if he can bail
the bankers out, give him $1 trillion.
I think it's, you can get a couple
of fucking who is, you know,
forget about the girls who have a
fucking uniform fetish. Um, but anyways,
uh, yes. So I got, I
got fucking trashed. Um,
I took a little heat off of Mel Gibson.
I bet.
Then he heard a couple of less fucking
hate mails last week, so I apologize.
I don't know who she is.
I'm not gonna Apologize For my stupidity,
but in the future when it's
something, you know, race-related I,
I will try to be a little more
informed. All right, well,
I've got to find this fucking email with
this guy fucking trashed me. You know,
he said, uh, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah. Let's see. He goes,
it starts off good. Just trashing
me, which I totally get it. He goes,
just like in your bit, you did
about the Jimmy, the Greek thing.
It's best for white people to just
leave it alone. Dr. Laura May be old,
but she's aware enough to
know what happens to white
people when they say the n
word or bring up racial
supremacy theories. See,
that's the part of the tape I did.
I showed up,
showed
up late to that rally. You
know, by the time I showed up,
they'd already put the cross
out. You know, everybody's
hoods. They took him off.
It was a hot day.
I didn't know what I was walking into.
I thought it was like a fucking, you
know, a meeting or something. You know,
we're all over by the table. I haven't,
don't, it's my fault. I came in late. Um,
so anyways,
he said the podium comes out.
So I'm surprised you defended
Dr Laura in this case.
They asked where I got a lot of them
surprise you. Defend it or can we,
cause I watched eight seconds of
the tape because I'm Maura. Um,
I don't understand why there's
any debate about racial int, Eh,
why any debate about racial inequality
always comes down to comedians and def
comedy jam. I don't think it does,
but evidently a, in your world,
maybe it does. Um, I've heard
this argument before, well,
black comedians say this and that
about white people and say the n word,
why can I, is it fair for minority
comedians but put up data and all basic,
all that's all that shit. Uh, I'm
trying to get to this part here.
So then he was talking about this
documentary where some comic was saying,
you know, making a joke, this is actually
a good joke where white people like,
why can't I say the n word? Uh,
and then the dude was like, Oh,
it was Chris Rock. Well, why
do you even want to say it?
Right. Great. Fucking joke.
Totally makes sense. And then the
punchline is, I've sailed the world.
I've fucked Raquel Welch.
If I could just say the n word,
my life would be complete. Uh, then
this do rights after that. He goes,
I think that it bothers white people
because you're not used to being told that
you can't do something.
Why people used to be able to
do and say anything they wanted.
Now there's all these rules.
Isn't that fucking that,
that part of the email. That's where it
just went off the fucking rails for me.
You know what I mean? It's like I
totally get it. She's a fucking idiot.
I didn't realize it because I watched
that short little clip, you know,
I shouldn't have support that shit.
And, and you're offended by that,
which I totally get. And then
in the end, you make some dumb,
general generalization about white
people. See, we're all the same.
We're fucking morons.
Jesus Christ.
I've sailed the world. Fuck walk.
How we'll see. That part's the joke.
But this here is what he writes bothers
white people that you're not being used
to told, being told that you
can't do something. Oh yeah, yeah.
We just run around doing whatever the
fuck we want to do. It's great. Ah,
Jesus Christ.
That's one of the great stereotypes
is that we're all Kennedy's living on
fucking Martha's vineyard
rather than fucking,
yeah.
You know, the majority of
white people are out there.
Majority of white people sitting
in cubicles not living their dream,
drowning in a sea of fucking debt,
trying to get health insurance.
Isn't that the majority of fucking
white people? Evidently not.
Evidently according to this guy,
white people have yachts
sailing the world. All 300
million of us, you know?
Do you just see it during that, the Gulf
War, uh, the Gulf spill there, you know,
that was one of the biggest problem.
All those white people,
all the 300 million white people with our
fucking yards, just sailing around. Oh,
it's so awesome to be white. You can
just walk up, you can do what it say,
whatever you want to do.
It's fucking incredible. Um,
that's an argument I've, I've
gotten to, uh, with the, um,
I think every fucking,
yeah.
Female comics, black comics, every fight.
They just go, yeah, it's easy for you.
All you gotta do is show up,
man. Oh yeah, that's all it is.
I don't even audition. I just lay here
and they call me up and I'm like, why?
Why did you give me that part then?
Cause your white, here you go.
You don't have to work
for shit. Uh, you know,
that's that class, you know, that's that
fucking double standard right there. Okay.
Now we're opening a whole
nother can of worms.
Let's talk race for the next
couple of weeks. People.
This ought to bring out a lot of ugliness.
Um, that's that classic fucking like,
that's one of those statements like you,
if you flip that thing,
what you just said there,
that generalization that you made of
white people that basically what we just
sit around and they do.
People just give a shit and we can
do whatever the fuck we want to do.
You're basically going to
define us by the Illuminati.
Um,
if you flip that around and somebody
white says that about another race of
people than there are in like a
Mel Gibson situation. All right,
now I'm open this up for discussion.
I'm not opening this up for
fucking rednecks to come
on here and be like, yeah,
that's why the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm not saying it like that,
but what I'm saying, you know
what? This is what I've learned.
Traveling the fucking Globe
and by the globe. I mean,
I went to two other continents.
I went to Australia and Europe.
I did all my research with just white
people. All right. And uh, yeah,
I think pretty much people
are people. We're all the
same. You know, there's a few,
like very small percentage of people on
this planet are genuinely good people
and everybody else is
pretty much full of shit.
And everybody looks at everybody else
and they think they got it easier.
And all you gotta do is l
you've got to do is this,
I got to work twice as hard as this guy
and this guy does this and you know,
no one wants to know
what I've learnt. Well, you probably
don't to know because I'm a fucking moron.
But for what it's worth,
this is what I've learned in
life is that life isn't fair.
It's really fucking difficult.
But if you bust your ass,
you're gonna make it on whatever
level you're going to fucking make it.
You surround yourself with positive
people and you don't fucking quit when
somebody kicks you in the fucking chest,
you get back up again.
You don't walk right into his foot.
You go around finding different fucking
avenue or maybe build your own avenue.
You do whatever you're
going to fucking do.
And everybody's got different
starting positions and all that shit,
and it isn't fucking fair and there's
nothing you can fucking do about it. But,
uh,
you know,
and there's some people who don't get
stuff because of who they are because
they're there. So they're dad
or they're fat or that they're,
they're fucking in an
Asian guy with one leg.
Okay. And he can't work at a Goddamn
fucking place. We get a fake Tan,
you know? Yeah. That shit definitely
fucking exists. But you know,
what are you gonna do? You
know? But you know what?
I think most people don't make it because
they're fucking pussies and they just
tap out, you know? And I'm
talking about fucking wipe.
I'm actually talking mostly white people,
cause that's what I know, you know?
And I got, I got people, people I know,
they just fucking quit and they got all
these fucking excuses why they can't
fucking do it. And it's
like, no, you, you quit,
you got punched once in the face and then
you just fucking laid down and I going
to fucking blame everybody else.
Right. Did that make any fucking sense?
I'm trying to say something positive here.
Trying to be balanced where
it's like, I know, you know,
like female comics, they're always
fucking complaining, but you know,
I can't tell you the amount
of fucking times I would,
I would be auditioning for festivals and
the industry becoming up to me going,
we need funny women.
Where are the funny women?
And then they would pick a fucking
woman just cause they needed one.
Not because they were one of
the funnier fucking people.
I'm not saying that female comics
aren't funny, but I'm just saying there.
There are examples. You know what?
You guys can all go fuck yourself.
I'm a balding redhead trying to get
into movies. All right? You know,
cry me a fucking river. I
don't give a shit. All right?
But I was wrong about the
doctor Laura thing. Okay?
When I start a fucking group crying
about how there's no fucking redheaded
action heroes out there. You know,
Jesus Christ. What's that fucking movie?
That's number one movie in the country.
They got 58 fucking action stars in there.
One of them can't be a redhead.
Couldn't call up David Caruso to show
his pasty white ass walking up to
Arnold Schwartzenegger. Ah, gives a fuck.
All right, so there you go. That was,
that was my, that was my roundabout
apology. Uh, no, seriously.
I really felt bad about that.
Felt like an ignorant ass at a rather
than just immediately come on and
apologize.
I left it up there for the week,
so I get my nice pounding from everybody
and uh, yeah. You know what I mean?
I fuck around and said a lot of
fucked up shit, but I, you know,
I'm trying to start your week off right.
I'm not trying to Piss you off,
although there's probably a lot of women
out there who had fucking disagree,
but you know, it's comedy. You
know, people, people get hurt.
That's how it fucking works.
This is the worst apology over,
but it's coming from the heart. All
right, rights. Go Fuck Yourself.
That's how we got to end it all right.
I grew up with no hugs,
so if I'm trying to be fucking nice,
it has to end with go fuck yourself.
Um, speaking of go fuck yourself.
Um, I just got back from
in Portland, Oregon and I had a great
time up at the a helium comedy club,
the grand opening helium
comedy club and Portland,
Oregon is a city that I
have not worked in, um,
in 10 years because there was no comedy
club for a guy in my situation to come
in there and work. Uh, I, I did work,
there was a local club there but it
wasn't really a comedy club. It was,
but it wasn't like the club owner.
This is basically what he would do.
He would paper the room,
which is a, the showbiz term.
He would just just call people up and I
talk about this last week I came fuckin
remember he would just call
people up and just say, you know,
or have this whole team of telemarketers
call up people and tell them that they
want a comedy show.
And he would just call enough people
where he would fill up his room every
fucking night of the week from Tuesday
through Sunday. And uh, everybody carried,
got in for free.
And then all he did was fucking just
throw food and drinks down their fucking
throats. And that's how he makes
his million. But meanwhile,
the comedian stands on stage in front
of a bunch of fucking drunk overeaten
jackasses who could give
a fuck about the show.
And you had to go up there on a Tuesday
night with a goddamn whipping a chair,
two shows, Friday, three
shows Saturday the guy would,
he wouldn't even let you
talk to the waitstaff.
You'd think if you put a
comedian through that bullshit,
they can at least try to get fucking leg,
you know,
try to get a little bit of action.
He fucking cock block you on
like nine different levels.
It's a fucking horrific Gig,
is what I'm telling you.
And then the second you got a
TV credit and you said, hey,
can I have an extra quarter the
next time I fly across the country?
And then the guy that you just wouldn't
return your phone call. So he basically,
other than up and coming guys would
just be booking horrific talent.
So Portland has been really starved
for any sort of national headliners.
So now there's a new club out there and
I was really excited to be the first guy
to come to town and uh,
and have, uh, you know,
work the comedy club.
And I had no idea how bad that other
club was until I talked to some of the
younger comics. This guy told me,
he walked in there to do with spot.
He moved up from,
uh,
from host to feature in that club owner.
Guy Calls him and he's like, look,
I make $1 million a
year just selling food.
That's what he said.
When you get on stage,
no f bombs. It just reads them the
fucking riot act. It's, it was horrible.
It's great business model.
He's made his money,
but it's fucking horrible for
the development of Comedians.
He's just sitting on their fucking chest.
Okay.
And that Dick's, he's not even letting
them get fucking lay. What did they,
you know, just asshole
fucking asshole. Um,
so it's great that there's a new comedy
club out there and that the, you know,
there's another place for these comics
to work and that they can actually see
national headlines.
Cause that was a fucking big thrill for
me when I was back in Boston. So, uh,
so if you live in the Portland area,
you know, if you're a lumberjack,
climbed down out of the fucking tree
and come on down and do a helium comedy
club. It's a great club. And uh,
he's got C's who's he got next week?
He's got a
Jimmy Pardot
is who he's got Jimmy Pardot a right.
Is that what is what I think
there was one other person, um,
oh,
Reggie watts.
Reggie rots on Wednesday and then Jimmy
Pardot from the never not funny podcast.
Jesus Christ. I'm losing my goddamn
memory. I knew there was somebody else.
So go check out those
shows next week and uh,
support a comedy club that actually
will book somebody who's funny and on
television. All right, low
plowing ahead here. Um,
what's the next thing on the docket? I
really have. I don't have shit this week.
Do I have one of my 17 minutes in?
That's not bad.
You gonna fucking tap out
at 40 minutes yet. You know,
you guys don't go home early every once
in awhile and just fake a fucking injury
at work. Try to pretend like a
forklift drove over here or some shit.
You know what I really wanted to do was
I wanted to up that five hour energy
here on the Internet,
five hour energy.
Now this is how I do my research now.
Five hour energy I think is a liquid
cocaine and I think it really fucks with
you yet. I think it's bad. So, um,
rather than just look up five
hour energy consumer reports,
I'm going to search five
hour energy unhealthy. See,
and this is how most people do research.
They already have their mind made up
and then they just read shit that agrees
with them,
you know,
according to a fuck face.com um,
I'm exactly right.
Side effects of five hour energy drink
shots. Are they unhealthily unhealthy?
Let's read this one. This is the first one
that came up. Side effects of fibers. A.
Okay.
I was at lunch today and my friend was
trying to get someone to drink five hour
energy caffeine shot.
So I,
I opened it and smelled it
and said I'd give it a shot.
Anyways, I think you're
supposed to mix them in a drink,
but I straight shrugs that, chugged
it, and almost gagged from the taste.
After I swallowed it, it took me like
15 minutes to get that horrible taste.
Uh, out of my mouth. I tried
eating food, chewing gum, drinking,
but the taste stayed in my
mouth for like 40 minutes.
I felt sick every time I
thought about the taste,
I think the tastes bothered me so
much. Ah, Jesus. Why you do research?
Are you going to get to the part where
you had the heart attack so I can feel
like I'm right?
Yeah.
Take the taste bothered me so
much caffeine. But anyways,
I'm shy. So after the tastes
and the sickness wore off,
I was feeling great all day and I felt
probably the happiest I have all school
year because all my subtle tendencies
wore off and I acted more outgoing and
funny like I do around friends.
They just turn this dude
into a fucking coke head.
That's classic reason why people
do drugs. Helps me loosen up, man.
I could talk to the chicks.
Um,
there's nothing on here.
Are you shitting me?
Oh, gives a fuck. I just, you know,
why don't you get eight hours sleep? Why
don't you do, why did you start that?
You know,
I had somebody else,
another mother call in or call in or
write in going back to that fucking a,
that shit I said about stay at home moms
and once again they were doing, she was,
she was saying, I totally agree with you.
I understand. You're absolutely right.
They have no right to be saying
it's the most difficult job ever.
And then she wrote three paragraphs about
how difficult it is to be a mother and
to be worrying up and
having the responsibility of
another life. And it's like,
I like, I don't, I get it. I know I don't
totally get it cause I don't have a kid.
But you know enough already. Alright,
like that other listeners
said you chose to be a mother.
You know you're acting like a,
all of a sudden you've got
like a fucking terminal disease
and all you're doing is bringing up
the bad shit. What about when you have,
you have a bad day and you
come home and that kid with,
you know all that innocent just
looks at you and just thanks.
You're bigger than life. What about
that? Doesn't that, that, that, you know,
wash away some of the spittle
on your shoulder blade?
I don't fucking know. You know,
it's funny, actually ironic. It was,
I was just watching 60 minutes and they
have one of those guys on the fucking BP
oil rig and I said when
they jumped off of it,
it was the equivalent of jumping off
a three story fucking brownstone.
Evidently it's the equivalent of
jumping off a 10 story fucking building.
That's what they did.
That was their choice.
Standing there in the middle
of the goddamn ocean either.
I burn up. All right.
Jump into the fucking oily water
without, oh, it was brutal.
Okay, so while you mom's stand the
fuck down, stop giving me shit.
I was just fucking joking around.
I'm just gonna have to end up
apologizing to everybody here.
You know I had somebody ran into me today
from a New Zealand podcast is really
going to be random.
Somebody wrote into from a New Zealand,
I was thinking about this topic that
for people in all these random countries
who listened to this podcast,
I'm going to start nominating who I think
the coolest person from your country.
Yes, and with new New Zealand,
I think it's a no brainer.
It's Phil Rudd.
You don't get any cooler than that guy.
He's played the exact same drum beat for
fucking 35 years and he's such a tough
bastard that no one has the balls
to tell them to switch it up.
You don't feel like, how about boom,
check, boom, check, check. You know,
how about that
fucking guy?
The whole fucking,
the whole goddamn album.
I think he just goes in there,
right?
And he just starts fucking playing
that beat and then they just,
they just play the whole song,
the whole fucking album worth of socks.
And then when they're done, they
just, they just started yet fail.
Okay,
fail. It's over. We're done.
Yeah. We made another album.
He just like, oh, all right. Yeah.
Just starts breaking down his kit
out cheese. I got nothing. I
really riffing about Phil Rudd.
What's some of the wars beat box. And
you're ever gonna fucking here. Um, oh,
here we go. You know what? I got to read
this right here. Now I've got something.
This will take up a good three fucking
minutes. You know what? I liked it.
This podcast is this difficult. Now
you guys can relate to me. You know,
you sitting there and you Goddamn
cubicles on a fucking Monday unless you're
white, of course you're out on your yacht.
You know, chat it up with the Kennedy.
Hey, when's the stock market going
to crash again? Give me the heads up.
Don't tell the Puerto Ricans.
That's what it's like.
That's exactly what it's like.
Okay.
There's not white people
work in farms.
Slaves to corporations.
Yeah.
Ah, not at all. Not at all. All you
do, you, you don't have to get up.
You don't even have to get up.
I spent nine years in bed just because
I was white and they just fucking
hilarious.
I made more money then than when I worked.
That's how great it is to be white.
It's so fucking easy.
And thank God for people who aren't white,
who've never been white to tell
me what it's like to be white.
It's fucking awesome.
Let me tell you something about being
white white guy. This is how good it is.
Oh yeah. What do you reincarnated,
what's your name? Frank,
in another life. Um, is that a white guy
name? I don't fucking know. All right.
So anyway, so I've pissed off a bunch
of people and uh, I just want to,
I just want to try and redeem myself
and show you that it's not all bad. I,
that's not all bad. You know, I do inspire
some people. Uh, here's one for you.
Milk white thighs is the name of this.
This email.
Somebody sent me a said bill,
a few things.
The last five years I've been
six feet tall, 240 pounds.
Upon trying to work out with
no results and no willpower,
I usually lose five pounds,
give up and sit in each shit.
However, you talked on the podcast a few
weeks ago about Bill Clinton and Al Gore
sloshing around the White House.
I believe I said sashaying around the
White House with their milky white hips.
Um, I was in a quiet room with
about 15 people and blurted, blurt,
laughed out loud, laughed
loudly, blurt laughed loudly.
That's really worded strangely. You
burst out laughing. There we go.
Ever since then,
I will be sitting watching TV,
looking at my treadmill
and I will say to myself,
slosh your ass up there and work off those
milky white hips or something to that
effect. It makes me laugh every time
and realize how pathetic I've been.
It's been about three weeks of this every
day and 45 minutes on the treadmill.
I'm down to 208 pounds.
Well on my way to my goal
of a hub of a buck 80. Also,
I'm a dude and my name is Lindsey.
I know you don't have a
lot of female listeners,
so if you ever feel like you need a
quote or just a woman's approval on
something, you do, feel free
to use my name and just say,
yeah, this chick Lindsay,
I know this chick,
Lindsey, you digs it. Uh,
I'm more than willing to compromise my
sexuality for the furthering of your
career.
Um,
I would buy five of anything, Bill burrs
endorsing. All right. There you go.
There's a good email. Congratulations.
You're down to 208. Keep going.
And, uh, I'm glad. You know,
I'm glad I just didn't bring all
negativity to the podcast this past week.
I felt fucking about that even though
I've been kind of a count again this week.
That's what I do. You know,
you came back, didn't you?
You know, I don't know any better.
I'm just a white guy laying in bed.
I can't remember the last time
I've had disappointment in my life,
which just doesn't happen. Just
doesn't happen. You know, you know,
sometimes the sale on my schooner
will break and I'm just like, AH,
Jesus Christ. And then I call the
government and I say, Hey, can you uh,
can you send me another one? They're
like, why and what color are you? I said,
why they guy? There you
go. Right on the way.
You know, I agree with the first half of
the email. This guy I'm making fun of,
but I would love to send this guy
my fucking taxes. I really would.
These mother fuckers,
what a lot of people don't realize is
that rich people feel there's enough rich
people and they got all kinds of fucking,
they take a fucking pipe to your God
damn knees every fucking quarter.
They make sure they can only be,
they can only be a certain number that
are a fucking rich people unless you just
invent some shit. Like,
uh, I dunno. I Dunno what
if you come up with the technology
for the fucking iPod then even then,
I mean they'll just, they'll just hire
you on as like a scientist. Right.
I'm really getting to know over my
fucking head here. You know what I mean?
Do you come up with Facebook?
If you invent that?
I think that's the way now that you
can actually become fucking rich,
but I'll tell you right now, it's not
fucking telling jokes. Fucking assholes.
Fucking assholes.
Yeah.
God. Damn. Fucking quarter.
I gotta I gotta. Oh Gee.
I am going to get into it.
I'm going going to fucking get it.
Just give me some me so
fucking mad. You're telling
me I think I'm getting ahead.
Look at me. Yeah, I'm getting
the hey a fucking sit down.
That's what they do every quarter.
You sit the fuck down.
You stay right where you're at.
Hey, sit right where you're at.
It's what it is. Anybody else?
This isn't even a color thing.
Anybody else in the fucking middleclass.
There you go. Fucking rich pricks
fucking last goddamn eight years,
but then making a ton of fucking money
and then all of a sudden the shit hits
the fan and they run out
of the Goddamn restaurant.
Leave everybody else
with the fucking check.
Fucking unbelievable.
My ever going to get that fucking car.
I'll tell you,
I got off the plane today and somebody
had the dodge challenger and the all
white, like the vanishing point guys
ever see that movie with that dude?
Kuwalski he's getting an all white
chargers. So they did this tribute to,
it's all fucking white and the guy
had these fucking rims on it and uh,
yeah,
I just sat there drooling at it. My
girls looking at me like, she's like,
Jesus Christ, you were obsessed with
that car. It's like, yeah, you know,
I am. Okay. Well, you know, I'm standing
here. You just get off the plane.
You could say hello to me.
You know,
I know what that reminds me of.
I fucking went to go to this pizza place.
I really try to do fun things. When I
was in Portland, tried to be healthy.
I went for a fucking hike. I was
sticking with my smoothies, you know,
dropping pounds here and uh,
yeah.
Anyway, somebody tells me that in, in
Portland they have this fucking wreck.
They got this pizza parlor where they
had the best God damn pizza and all the
fucking northwest.
So this guy has like this homemade goddamn
doe and he only makes so much of it
every day. And when he's done making
the dough, he's done making pizza.
Go Fuck Yourself. All right? So
I'm like, you know, well shit,
I gotta try this pizza. So I go on the
Internet, I look up, I see where it is.
It's right on Hawthorne Street,
like 45th and Hawthorne,
46 in Hawthorne, something like
that. Right? So I'm like all,
I gotta go check this fucking thing out.
So I allow,
I get myself an hour and a half before
the show to get there to get a God damn
pizza. Right? It's a fucking
pizza. Okay. So I call up,
just told me to cut just
to call this place. And uh,
I call up the,
it rings like 11,
12 fucking times and nobody picks up.
So I'm guy.
You know what? They're probably
busy. No big deal. I got an hour,
I'll get there an hour and a half
before, right? I get a goddamn cab.
I'm driving over there. Cab driver
goes out. Just to let you know,
this guy's kind of like the
pizza Nazis, like, like the,
like the fucking a soup Nazi on Seinfeld.
So I show up and I walk in. Lo
and behold, the place is packed,
but I see this little two top gets up,
waitresses cleaning off the table,
she walks away.
So I go over and I sit down,
get re order the pizza,
I'm checking out what people are ordering
of getting excited is what I'm trying
to tell you. And then the weight
just comes over. She's like, um,
were you over in the waiting room next
door or did you just like walk in here
and sit down? And I was like, um, I
just came in and sat down. She goes,
yeah, you have to like thein in, um,
next door and all those people,
everything's,
everything's a question you
have to like sign in next door.
And I'm like, oh, all right. I go, well,
how long is the wait? She's like, wow,
I can't really like say it's, you
know, it's kind of as a, at that point,
he's like a quarter of, I go,
well, I've got to show at eight,
a quarter to 7:00 AM I going to have
time to order a pizza and eat it?
She's like, yeah, now, now
and um,
and then that's when my blood starts
fucking boiling because I realized what I
just walked into.
You know what I walked into?
I walked into the pizza version of
pink's hot dogs out here in fucking La,
the pizza version of magnolia bakery in
new city or that fucking place where you
get the hot dogs in Chicago,
you know,
hour and 15 minutes to
make a fucking pizza.
You can't do that sky sitting
here acting like, you know,
like he's making some sort of gourmet
for now. I'll tell you right now,
that's my overrated for the fucking week.
Standing in line at any restaurant.
These, you know, the, the, the
breakfast place in your neighborhood,
your girlfriend's like,
oh my God,
this stuffed French toast is to die for
and you stand there and fucking line.
Never worth it. It's never
worth the hype, okay?
You learn anything from this podcast
other than I'm an ignorant asshole.
Don't ever stand in line for
fucking food. Okay? And less some,
there's a natural disaster.
The places flooded and this,
they're scooping out fucking pea soup.
You know when you're putting
it into your baseball hat,
then you'll stand in line. Soup
kitchen. You stand in line,
but don't stand outside these fucking
places. It's stupid. It's never worth it.
You know fancy restaurants. You
don't stand outside. You call up,
you make a fucking reservation.
But I'm not standing out there
like I'm waiting to fucking
did they even make goddamn sense.
You know what I mean?
He's fucking people in New
York. They stand outside for
90 minutes for a cupcake,
for fucking cupcake. It's gone in three
seconds. You're just going to Piss me off.
Is some people in Portland.
Okay.
They're actually going to figure out
what pizza parlor I'm talking about and
then they're going to tile. Tell me, dude,
it's totally fucking worth at
these low self esteem Douche bags
who just allow themselves to get totally
treated like absolute fucking shit for
pizza. Yeah. Sorry,
I can't make you a pizza within an hour
and 15 minutes. Well, you know what?
Fuck you and your fucking pizza.
What do you think about that and
your number one goddamn rating.
I'll go to pizza hut.
Eat their fucking slop.
Doug, you got to kill him. He is that.
I know. I'm going to have to go back.
I have to try it.
People hyped it so much.
That's what I'm really mad about is I
know as much as I just fucking talked
about that shit,
I'm going to have to go back down and go
get it and for all you guys wonder and
yelled at Magnolia. It's a great
cupcake, but it's not that great.
It's not that great to have to stand there
and listen to that awful conversation.
Now if people driving by looking at you,
trying to figure out what are
they standing in line for,
you know,
is the president,
they're doing a book signing.
Is there a porn star there was going
to blow you at the front of the line.
Can I raise the stakes for something
funny within the last seven minutes?
All right. Fuck this. Fuck
this podcast. Here we go.
Why don't I nominate some youtube
videos for the week? Everyone. Um,
I have a ton of them and I'm going to
make the bold rex Ryan statement that I
think pretty God damn soon,
if not already, the MLM,
podcast.com it's going to have the best
fucking youtube video collection of
youtube videos. All right. I mean,
cause you guys are on the cutting edge.
A lot of these videos that you guys
send me, they only got like, you know,
10,000 to 40,000 fucking hit.
Some of them have like a hundred thousand
or so like that and even a few with a
million. But if they're really
funny, I don't give a shit,
but I think that we're on the
cutting edge of some shit.
Like here's two that I found
that, you know, only, you know,
in the tens of thousands of hits. So
I'm assuming you haven't seen them. Uh,
look up a prank of the century.
This woman puts on a mask and scares
the shit out of this other woman. And,
and it's, you gotta watch it. It's
fucking great. And then piss off.
Pissed off.
Cat freaks out.
Yeah,
look up that one. Um, and we got a lot
of people, you guys like violent shit.
I'm trying to categorize them now.
And by the way,
the MM podcast is the official fan page.
There's the Monday morning podcast.
If you don't have to,
you know,
it's a pain in the ass to go on youtube
and try to find six different videos,
right? Typing it in and all
that shit. You're going to
get caught. You're at work,
you're not supposed to be doing it,
but if he just subtly type in the Mlm,
podcast.com and nobody's fucking looking,
all of them are going to be right there.
And you can watch one after another,
you know, or you can make it
last the whole fucking day.
You can even drink that five hour fucking
energy and just start screaming at
your screen if you want. It's
all up to you. Um, so anyways,
uh, here's a couple of, for you fight
fans out here. I will start slow.
Look up a choke slam.
Um,
I hope that's the name
of the fucking video.
Just referee reffing a fight and this,
it's a choke slam.
Look it up. All right. Um,
here's kind of a cute one. Says little
girl boxer. It's actually a boy.
His name's pretty Boyd. Bam, Bam. And
you gotta look at this fucking kid.
This kid would kick the shit.
Just imagine this kid fighting
another fifth grader. Um,
and this is the most insane one.
Boston Street fight guy with bat does
damage Boston Street fight guy with bat as
in baseball bat does damage.
Um,
what else do we got?
Some ridiculous is something ridiculous.
Swollen in south Philly.
It's a guy walking around like he's got
a fucking hard on having conversations
with people. Sort of an old
bit. I've seen it done before,
but this guy does a
great, um, wrestling fans.
We've got two for you.
A macho man on Coke and a ultimate
warriors confession is absolutely fucking
brilliant. You've got to look
at that one. And, uh, Oh,
more violence office worker goes insane.
Second Angle.
Evidently there's some new
footage. Uh, what else?
Oh, this is a great one.
Look up the turtle, man. This
one might be my favorite.
This guy's missing all his front teeth.
And when you find out how
he's missing his teeth,
it's just one of the great stories
that he g just alludes to it.
It's fucking awesome. It's just this
redneck who just fucking catches turtles.
And a,
I swear to God,
I would pay admission to sit on the
side of the pond and just watch this guy
catching turtles. It's fucking hilarious.
And I actually getting into covers,
we talk about the worst
covers of all time.
Here's a great one of the best covers
I've ever seen just as far as being
creative.
Look up a stairway to heaven,
the beatniks and that's all
one word, B, e. A. T. N. I. X.
It's fucking cool as hell.
It's really fucking cool.
They do stairway to heaven the way the
Beatles would do it. It's really fucking,
I dunno, it's really creative. Um,
and speaking of movies,
here's one for you is, uh,
I got in this conversation
with somebody on the Internet.
They sent me an email and they were
talking about how, uh, you know,
they're not married yet,
so they're kind of hanging out with
people who are younger than them,
so they get a little bummed out when
they make references to movies that
nobody's seen before. So, uh, he started
showing him some of the classics,
like the dirty dozen and that type
of shit. And he asked me, you know,
what are some of the great fucking movies,
uh,
I should recommend with then let it to
like music and that type of shit. And,
uh, here's a new topic for you. Is
it, do you guys have like songs?
You must have these, these fucking
songs that the second you hear him,
you can't hear the song without thinking
of the movie. You know what I mean?
Of course you do. Here, I'll give you
a classic fucking example. And, uh,
I think even the broads will know
this one. Did I get rid of it?
I had it all fucking cued up.
I really am the worst.
Can I ever do this?
This is why I started off in fucking
radio and then my career quickly ended
because I would do the whole beginning.
You're listening to 6:40 AM
WEC be broadcast service,
the fucking whatever the fuck I
used to say. Hang on a second.
Let me get to youtube. God dammit, Bill.
Yeah.
And now there's a lull. See what happens.
You know what? I'll play the other one.
Well, no, I can't do that. Have the end
and ability to do that shit. All right,
let me set the mic down. Hang on a
second. All right. Do you want it?
She act like your work and for once.
All right,
now I'm yelling at you
because I fucked up.
What the hell's the name of that
fucking Sabata oh, something.
Something, something. Something.
Um, air. It is. I got it.
Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Oh,
you fucking content. Come on. Come up.
Should I edit this out?
You know what this is
like is when you fucking,
someone just told you what their
name is and then somebody you know,
comes walking in and you go to introduce
them and you have no fucking idea who
they are. That's how I'm speaking
right now. All right. What,
what movie does this remind you of?
Instantly?
Come on. You know what? You
know the movie, right? I
know. Most of you know though.
Even abroad's we'll get
it. Come on. You know this,
I'll wait for the breakdown.
I'll wait for the breakdown of it.
Where the hell is it?
How was it? I had this whole fucking
thing queued up. This part right here.
You don't remember this?
Ah,
[inaudible]
I haven't did the sound effects.
Remember that reservoir dogs,
when he cuts the fucking dude's ear off.
I used to love that Goddamn song and
I couldn't listen to it for 10 years.
Cause every time I fucking heard it,
I just thought about Marvin Nash
getting his Goddamn ear cutoff.
Stop.
Stop yelling at him.
Fuck yeah.
What a great piece of acting
by both of those guys who ever
played Marvin Nash. And, uh,
Mister Blonde. I can never remember
people's fucking names. Uh,
we'll call him Vince Gilligan. I Dunno
his fucking name and I want to fuck that.
I forget his name.
Yeah.
You know, most guys to play a psycho
would act like a fucking psycho.
How they think a psycho supposed to act,
you know,
and it just how fucking Cami was, you
know, that's what's really fucking scary.
Somebody cut your ear off on
and act like a fucking maniac.
You almost start laughing
halfway through it. Like,
is this guy mocking being crazy? But
it's the calmness with which he does it.
Here's another one for you.
These are really easy for like guy movie.
So I need some more, more suggestions.
I'm actually going to disguise this one.
I downloaded this song because of the
movie and I didn't realize that this
fucking Irish dude babbles telling some
fucking story for 20 minutes before they
get to the part that I
actually recognized. Uh,
let's see if you can guess this
one. Here we go. What movie
goes to wear
shoes to the main blog
that does with Joyce and lettuce,
right? You're like, what the fuck is this?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I didn't,
I didn't want to get blood on the floor.
Yep.
Well you know it.
[inaudible]
hello audio.
Tion that's a Donovan singing a Atlantis.
That was from a,
the Billy bad scene.
When they start kicking the shit.
Fucking Billy bet.
Is there anything better than that
fucking camera when they're doing that?
Pointed up at Robert De Niro's character.
Jimmy just fucking kicking him.
Rick flair. Couldn't do fake
kicks better than Robert Dinero.
You know it just sitting
there kicking him.
See this was bad.
Billy batts was a made guy with
some real grease balls. Shit.
We did what we wanted.
We were wise guys. Right?
What's the last one I got here? So
I, I, you know, as usual, you know,
whenever people ask you these questions,
I can't end up, I can't remember them.
MMM.
Let's see.
Here's one for you.
This is actually an interesting
one that's really fucking obscure.
This is one from a movie that
the dude ended up selling.
This is from cool hand Luke.
All right,
for those of you who've seen cool hand
Luke, if you haven't seen cool hand Luke,
you've got to fucking watch that movie,
right?
And basically the guy who did
the score, uh, wrote this song,
there's a scene where they
have to tar this road and uh,
Paul Newman's character,
you know,
rather than just sitting there and being
like, this is a miserable fucking job.
He gets them all amped up that it's
supposed to take all fucking day,
but he gets these guys so fucking
amped up, they just, they just fucking,
they just,
it's like they took five hour energy
and before they just flying down the
fucking road and they're all laughing,
having a great fucking time when they
finished the road and they actually have
an afternoon off,
right?
So it was like Paul Newman's way
of saying fuck you to the, to the,
to the, to the screws. Is that what they
call them back down to the, to the guards.
Right. So they had to
have this music. So they,
this guy wrote this score for this scene.
Uh,
but the problem was it
was perfect for the movie,
but the problem was years later he sold
it or I don't know how far along he sold
it and it got played so much in this
other shit that it actually kind of fucks
up the movie. This is, this is the score.
This is going to be for some older
people to actually understand this is the
music that they had for the tea.
It's called tar sequence. When they,
when they tar the road
and they ended up selling,
the guy ended up selling the song
for something else. Here it is.
Just listen to this shit.
Ah,
you suck. God dammit. Fuck the, see.
This is why I got out of rain.
I used to do shit like that on the air.
That would be the worst break ever.
I am the fucking worst.
I want a great intro. I gave
that song. All right, here we go.
This is the tar in the road.
Totally makes sense.
Florida.
Good evening and welcome to the six news.
It was a four car accident.
The motherfuckers sold it to
every six o'clock news station.
This was the classic with
you fucking old like me.
Anytime the fucking news came on,
this is the fucking song that they played.
This is back when,
when they actually had fucking journalists
telling you what the corporations
wanted you to know.
Yeah.
Good evening. I'm Jake Johansen. What?
I say Jay, I'm a chickshaw Hansen.
I was, that's how fucked up my brain
is. I was trying to think a Chet Curtis.
I was like, well I can't say I can't
say Chet. That's an actual fucking name.
I don't name names. So then
I'll go, I'll go with Jake.
And then for some reason I don't.
It just got crossed up and I said,
Jake Johann's I gave Jake,
Joe answered a fucking shout out the best
God Damn Comedians the last fucking 20
years from my money.
Yeah.
So anyways, yeah, it's called
out of the tar sequence.
So that one actually doesn't remind
me of the, the, the, the fuck it.
That's a reverse one.
I actually watched the movie and I'm
getting into that scene and then I think
there's like all of a sudden I'm
going to start listening to the news.
So Jesus Christ,
that was,
that was probably the worst debut
of any segment. But you knew,
you got to admit you were
definitely into it, right?
I know you guys have suggestions.
Can you help me out? All right.
I'm fucking burned out
with this fucking podcast.
I'm trying to get ready to do other
shit and I'm just, you know, look at me.
I'm fucking supporting Nazis now is
that what I'm doing is then I'll fucking
tired. I am doctor Laura. If you're
not a bad birthday book and Moron,
all right, here's one for you. You know
what? I'm going to actually do one.
I'm going to do one here for it to try
and make peace after my doctor Laura. Uh,
Dr Laura comments. Here we go. Oh,
wait a minute. Wait a minute. I've
got to get a secretary for this shit.
All right. Where the fuck are we?
Yeah, I fucking hate you tube.
I don't want you douchebags doing the
fucking thing. I want the actual guy.
Everybody doing a fucking remix.
Wait, hang on. Hang in there.
There it is. [inaudible] we go. Alright.
Now, this one's mainly going to be
for, uh, the people that I offended
last week, last week,
uh, with the fuck is it?
Come on now. All right, here we go.
Here we go. This isn't going to remind.
This isn't going to remind you of a movie.
This is going to remind you of a TV show.
What show was this?
Hang on the last one.
Come on. Wait a minute.
You fucking cunt. I did.
I didn't hit pause. Did I?
Hang on.
All right,
this is going to remind you of a TV show.
What TV show.
I somehow missed that when that came
out. That is a, that's the Carlton Dance.
I think I was too old for that one. I
kind of tapped out with sitcoms after, uh,
after why happy days.
And I wanted the chairs.
I started Busan and actually
believed cheers. You know,
I believe that,
you know,
there was a bar like that and you come
in and just being an alcoholic was like
funny and fulfilling.
I guess there was the sadness.
He completely avoided his wife
fear and they never showed her. Um,
anyways, you know what? I think that's
going to be the podcast for the week.
I have to, I got a tap out
here, man. This, this, uh,
this trying to do one on the road the
day after I come off the road is really
difficult. But, uh,
fortunately things have been
going well that I'm really busy,
so I guess that is a good fucking thing.
But you know,
you get used to this comedian lifestyle,
you just get the fucking hang out
on a Monday. Now I actually, uh,
I have shit to do,
which is annoying.
It's not why I started being a comedian.
I started to be a comedian,
so I would not have shit to do,
you know,
wouldn't have a boss
to tell fucking jokes,
talk about my Dick in all 50 states
and whatnot. Believe it or not,
people, my neck stand up date
isn't until September 9th, uh,
at the comedy works in Denver, Colorado.
Let's blow through some dates, shall we,
by the way, uh, my tickets
for my big theater show,
my big theater tour that I'm doing,
um,
are on sale now. And, uh, I don't have
the fucking link do I? Where is it?
Oh, you got to live nation.com. Um,
slash bill bird tickets or you
just go to [inaudible] dot com.
You just click on any, any of the
dates here. I'm going to be a,
before the theater's tour starts.
I'm also going to be at Zany
Comedy Club in Nashville,
Tennessee on September 23rd,
24th and 25th,
one of, uh, one of my favorite clubs to
play as is the comedy works in Denver.
September 10th. Well, we
got there September 10th,
11th. I have September 9th,
10th and the 11th. There we go.
That's when I'm working there. Um,
and then starts to theater. Shit.
I'm going to be at the egg in Albany,
New York.
All you people in upstate New York
always say come to upstate New York, man.
What the fuck? I'm going to be
there. I'm going to be at the
egg in Albany,
New York.
And then the following day I'm going
to be at the center for the arts,
Buffalo, New York. Um,
so I'm finally coming to buffalo.
I'm actually hitting up a bunch of
towns that I haven't been to in fucking
forever. Uh, another city, a city.
I've never done standup in a full set.
I've done a guest set,
but I've never gotten a gig out there.
I'm going to be at the, uh, pantageous
Pantages pan and ages, whatever the
fuck it is, theater in Minneapolis,
Minnesota on October 22nd.
And then the following
day I'm going to be at
the Vic Theater in Chicago,
Illinois on, um, October 23rd.
And uh,
any other ones?
I got another theater date on November
19th and met the listener auditorium,
Washington DC.
And uh,
the last theater I have is
the more theater in Seattle,
Washington on November 27th.
Uh,
you can go on to bird.com and just click
on the links in the lower left hand
corner and you can check out
all that bullshit and uh,
hopefully you'll come out to the
shows. We'll see how it goes. Um,
for those of you wondering if I'm just
going to try and do theaters exclusively,
um, no, I am not. I'm always going to
be doing the clubs. The clubs are like,
the gym keeps you in shape, you
come in, you do five, six shows,
and then every once in awhile like,
uh, like Buffalo, I don't know,
they don't really have like a
big time comedy club out there.
No disrespect to anybody out there.
So why you just come in,
you try to do with theater. Same
thing with Albany, you know,
you start going to those really
smaller fucking towns, um,
or smaller comedy markets. And
then that's just when, you know,
the local comedy club is just
neat name like knee slappers,
you know? Um, God damn it, you're funny.
Who's ready to laugh? You know, they
just got awful fucking names and uh,
yeah. And they try to make
you stay in a comedy condo.
So that's why I always
avoided those things.
And I tried to stay in the
bigger markets where I could,
they actually put me in a hotel. I'm
like, you, I lie, like my comforts. So,
uh, that's, that's the big,
uh, my big tour coming up.
And there's also a date there I missed in
Columbus, Ohio. That's a club date, uh,
November 12th, 13th. And
14th and the fucking,
you know what kills me is how
quick that's all gonna go by.
And another year is going to
go by as well as, you know,
by the end of that tour, um, football
season will be three quarters over.
How fucking sad is that? At
least the regular season. Uh,
who do you like by the way?
Anybody.
Anybody for some predictions.
How about we try to do some predictions
and whoever comes the fucking closest
gets a, an autograph and
autographed DVD of my brand new DVD.
Let it go. Because by then it'll be the
end of the season and I'll fucking sent,
Nah, I'm not gonna do that then
you won't fucking buy it. Right.
I need to get you to buy it. Got,
damn it. I suck at marketing. Anyways,
that's a podcast for this week.
Was very disjointed. I, you know,
they can all be gold.
You know,
even Peyton manning throws an interception
every once in awhile on the file
drive of a fucking Superbowl,
doesn't he? Well, doesn't,
he actually saw what's his face? Uh,
drew Brees finally getting some props.
He came in there with John Gruden,
you know,
John Grooms got that
unbelievable intensity that,
that vein down the middle of his forehead.
That's one of my favorite
announcers out there are color men.
Whatever the hell that guy's doing,
that guy's the shit.
There's nothing better than
an ex football player at this.
This is provided that they
have broadcasting skills.
Somebody that played the game,
coached the game and that type of shit.
And then you get the classic
like broadcast or like a,
like an Al Michaels or something like
that to call the game. And then, uh,
then you got your crew.
Thank you bill.
Thank you for breaking that down
is if we didn't fucking notice,
why don't you just admit,
Bill,
that you just babbling at this point to
somehow try and make it to 'em up to 57
minutes. That qualifies. I
can tap out at this point.
Why don't you guys leave sometimes
three minutes before five.
So what did we learned this week?
We learned that even on major topics
like race bill really doesn't do his
research. Uh, we learned
that I had at why act, uh,
that got some fat guy with a milky white
ties to laugh at himself and he's lost
40 pounds. So I'm not totally
a bad guy. And uh, I guess
from the troops, come back,
send him a drink or get, get them,
get them a blow job or shut your face.
And evidently they, they, they
feel the same way of the support,
the troop bumper stickers as I do.
You like I'm taking one marine,
his point of view and just saying that
that's everybody's well that's what the
fuck I do. That's what I
do. Support the troops.
I always thought it was ridiculous.
A lot of those bumper stickers that said,
I support the troops. It's like,
well, why wouldn't you? What do you,
what are you rooting for the,
the other team.
So fucking obvious. I support the
troops. Ice Cream tastes good.
Okay.
I like babies.
You know what he's gonna have all kinds
of obvious bumper stickers on the back
of your fucking car. I saw a
guy at a big heart on, on his,
on his side of his house.
It said love our troops.
It just really gave me the creeps.
And every time I see it,
I want to fucking rip
it down. You know, I,
this other guy wrote me an angry fucking
email all about the politics about
sending the troops over there,
you know? And it's just like,
like he was fucking dropping
all this knowledge, man,
about what's really going on
with the war man. You know,
like, I don't realize, like
I don't realize that shit,
but I also realized that those guys
don't determine where the fuck they go.
All right? So I'll just try
not to be a dick. You know,
they got been a dick enough, haven't
I? I've gotta be honest with you.
I have no idea what I said
for the last 11 minutes,
but all I know is I recorded it and you're
listening to it. Okay. So who's worse?
May you guys just shaking your heads right
now? He's really losing his mind. Well,
maybe I am. Um, that's it.
So I got, I got like two,
three weeks off on be hanging out,
can be gone doing a lot of spots down the
comedy store. If you're in Los Angeles,
going to be working out my shit.
If you want to come down there and
watch me bomb, lean on the mic,
stand and stare at that. All weather
carpet is, I work out my bits,
uh, pop in down the comedy
store and that's it. Thanks.
Everybody wrote in it. Uh,
and that is it.
I'll talk to you guys next week.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].